[Musik]
breaking news
die generaldebatte im deutschen
bundestag meine damen und herren der
oppositionsführer friedrich merz hat
zuerst gesprochen und danach
bundeskanzler olaf scholz olaf scholz
hat auch auf die rede von selen ski
geantwortet dem ukrainischen präsidenten
der vor einer woche dort im bundestag
zugeschaltet war und gesagt hat wir
brauchen ihre hilfe heute eine woche
später sagte olaf scholz sie können sich
auf unsere hilfe verlassen allerdings
forderungen nach flugverbotszonen werden
wir nicht nachgeben solche forderungen
kommen aus kiew und da gehen wir hin zu
paul ronzheimer unserem reporter vor ort
paul habe ich können wir nicht sehen
können wir hören da bist du pauli wird
diese nachricht die definitiv
ausgesprochen wurde es wurde sogar
gesagt das sind rote linien wie wird
diese nachricht in kiew aufgenommen
du machst da gibt es unverständnis in
kiel weil man sich hier diese
flugverbotszone sehr gewünscht hat aber
neben dieser debatte wird ja in
deutschland viel über waffen gesprochen
und wir sind gerade in einem waffenlager
der ukrainische damit thomas und ich
möchte euch das einmal zeigen dass hier
ist eine deutsche
panzerabwehrwaffe wir sehen hier achtung
vor dem verschluss ist der kopfschutz
von der patrone zu entfernen hier sehen
wir die deutsche schrift auf dieser
panzerabwehrwaffe und die sind hier
angekommen in diesem lager
nicht genügend wie uns juli sagt ury des
dieser germanwatch
also mehr youcat und wie sie nutzen
youtube um zu verstehen wie mit dieser
panzer abwehrwaffe tatsächlich operiert
werden kann also youtube thomas ist der
instructor für die deutschen waffen
schon sehr skurril
julian evans die tour
de ski
also sie haben 40 von diesen deutschen
panzerabwehrwaffen hier mit ihr
verhalten aber sie haben bereits 20
verschossen und 20 benutzt thomas und
die medien gerne darin chance
alle zeigt uns jetzt einmal hier diese
deutsche panzer abgewartet
live aus berlin ist es so einfach ist es
ist nur einfach wie ein deutscher
volkswagens hast du hier also mitten in
einem waffenlager entschuldigung will
ich hier auch mal lachen in diesen
stunden aber das ist schon sehr skurril
also mit youtube funktioniert hier die
anleitung für diese deutsche
panzerabwehrwaffen und judith es ist so
einfach wie ein deutscher volkswagen und
wir brauchen mehr davon glaube ich man
kann es gar nicht begreifen aber an du
hast schon recht es wirkt in diesen
momenten auch ein wenig lustig paulas
uns nochmal eine sache kurz gemeinsam
anschauen du hast die rede von olaf
scholz vielleicht auch in teilen
verfolgt ansonsten wir spielen hier noch
mal gerne einen ausschnitt vor und zwar
sagt er dort er telefoniere sehr oft mit
wladimir putin und putin müsse die
wahrheit über diesen krieg erfahren und
auch das hat bei uns im studio für
aufregung gesorgt wir schon noch mal
rein
mit präsident selent ski habe ich mich
immer wieder über die lage und die
nächsten schritte ausgetauscht und auch
mit präsident putin habe ich in den
vergangenen tagen oft lang und intensiv
gesprochen
putin muss die wahrheit hören über den
krieg in der ukraine und diese wahrheit
lautet der krieg zerstört die ukraine
aber mit dem krieg zerstört putin auch
russlands zukunft die waffen müssen
schweigen und zwar sofort
das geht ja bei diesem satz durch den
kopf wladimir putin muss die wahrheit
über den krieg in der ukraine
ja ich gebe diesen satz gerne mal weiter
hier an juli weil das ist ja entscheiden
was die ukraine darüber denken juli oder
schwimmen parlament
[Musik]
er sagt er muss es verstehen und wir
werden ihnen das zeigen wir werden ihnen
das lehrerin also hier erneut die
klaren worte von ukrainischen soldaten
mit im bild die deutsche panzerfaust
noch einmal der sagt wir werden klagen
putin das schon zeigen die wahrheit über
diesen krieg also man sieht der
widerstand in der ukraine ist
ungebrochen und ich nehme euch hier
vielleicht einmal noch mal ganz kurz mit
denn so oft kommt man nicht hier in so
ein waffenlager wie das aussieht und wie
die leute hier auch arbeiten
juli steht dort bei den deutschen
panzerabwehrwaffen aber wir sehen hier
natürlich wie auch dinge repariert
werden buch geführt wird hier wir sehen
dort im hintergrund ein paar vertonen
wir sind dort waffen und wir sehen auch
hier hinter frische waffen die
angekommen sind in diesem moment
und in diese richtung
ebenfalls patron und dann gehen wir noch
einmal zurück juli wir keine chance
important things juli und juni 3
spezielle komplexe die passieren wird
ist irgendeine
also eher leute jetzt hier auch um anti
luftabwehr zum beispiel stinger die die
ukraine dringend brauchen das tut ja
auch immer wieder angesprochen also
neben den panzerabwehrwaffen auf singer
amazon oder vertrags aus
[Musik]
wie viel angst hat er davor dass auch
hier angegriffen werden könnten in
diesem moment
sind es geworden
also das ist das problem sagt er das ist
immer wieder zu angriffen aus der luft
kommt eben insbesondere auch auf einen
ort wo wir hier gerade stehen denn das
sind natürlich strategische ziele für
die russische armee gelöscht sondern
halte ich mir du bist
du risiko grinst
sogar wirklich gut gemacht
als er sagt die ukrainische armee die
kümmert sich um jeden einzelnen soldaten
aber die russische armee eben nicht und
jetzt gehen wir noch einmal zurück wie
gebäck in displays um noch einmal zu
zeigen dass nicht mehr so viele von
diesen panzerabwehrwaffen da sind und
dass sie neue brauchen also das sind die
vorräte hier ja was me you can film wir
sehen hier sozusagen die kisten
und das sind jetzt noch ungefähr sagte
von 40 sind noch 20 da juni how to get
here von germany die
devise
er sagt dass dafür nicht erzählen das
ist ein militärgeheimnis und tatsächlich
sandra und thomas ist es so dass die
russische armee unbedingt verhindern
will und wir zeigen hier nochmal drauf
kampfpanzer hier jahres schuldig
die russische haben wie will unbedingt
verhindern dass weitere von diesen
panzerabwehrwaffen hierher kommen nach
kiew denn das sind tatsächlich
effektive verteidigung methoden für die
ukrainische armee paul du wirst es nicht
glauben aber das ist sozusagen die
antwort auf die frage die friedrich merz
im bundestag heute gestellt hat was ist
denn überhaupt geliefert worden wo kommt
das denn an du hast es uns gerade
gezeigt und wir haben gelernt dass man
sich youtube videos anschaut tutorials
um diese panzerfäuste zu bedienenden
panzerfäuste wie juri dort sagt der
waffenmeister die so einfach zu bedienen
sind wie ein volkswagen wir müssen wir
uns das denn vorstellen wie werden diese
waffen verteilt kommen dann die soldaten
einfach rein dann in den keller und dann
kriegt jeder eine panzerfaust der ein
youtube video gesehen hat und dann geht
es los
die
flyers kamen
[Musik]
also es gibt einen akteur der sonst
seien die waffen auch mit verteilt und
dann werden diese waffen an die
frontlinie verteilt je nachdem wo welche
benötigt werden und dann wird mit diesen
deutschen panzerabwehrwaffen die
russische armee angegriffen um halten
kannst du vielleicht auch noch mal
nachfragen wie es sich für diese männer
anführt solche waffen zu benutzen die
sie ja tatsächlich noch nie in der hand
hatten das muss ja auch schwierig sein
ich meine wenn wir hier in deutschland
eine mikrowelle irgendwie in betrieb
nehmen und haben keine
betriebsanleitungen bei youtube gucken
okay aber das sind waffen
ist jesus
luz schoss oscar nacht der jugend heraus
nicht wo
der batterien ist von
soldaten die schon erfahren haben in den
vergangenen jahren seien insbesondere
das ist eine sowjetische woche in diesem
fall
also er sagt die sowjetische wache sehr
viel schwieriger zu betrieben als die
deutsche waffen und soldaten die
erfahrung haben die zum beispiel im
krieg seit 2014 schon gekämpft haben die
wissen dann auch sofort wie man diese
deutsche waffe bedient
über
die deutschen denken an die menschen
sagt er
paul noch mal wird die nachfrage und
auch ziemlich besorgte nachfrage 40 von
diesen panzer abwehrwaffen für ganz kiew
oder nur für dieses eine waffenlager
in
hohenlohe chirico switch ist hier in
london
selbst wenn er wüsste würde es uns nicht
sagen wird aber ich gehe davon aus es
gibt natürlich verschiedene
munitionslager auch an verschiedenen
stellen verschiedenen regionen von wo
aus das ganze verteilt wird was uns aber
alle sagen ist das ist längst nicht
reicht dass sie mehr von diesen anti von
diesen panzerabwehrwaffen brauchen ganz
dringend um hier sich weiter verteidigen
zu können und er sagt eben neben diesen
anti panzer waffen brauchen sie auch
dringend mehr um raketen abschießen zu
können auch um sozusagen flugobjekte
abschließen zu können denn das ist die
größte gefahr momentan insbesondere für
kiew das durch drohen auch dieses
gebäude ausspioniert werden könnte und
es dann zu einem luftangriff oder einem
raketenangriff genau diese positionen
kommen könnte wo wir gerade stehen denn
das ist die taktik der russischen armee
man möchte versuchen so zu sagen die
logistischen zentren kaputt zu machen
die logistischen zentren zu zerstören um
damit den waffennachschub zu brechen
weil das ist ja das muss man ja einmal
festhalten olaf scholz schließt also aus
dass die nato sich sowohl an
friedenstruppen als auch an einer
flugverbotszone beteiligen würde schickt
aber nicht genügend flugabwehrraketen
oder waffen
so klingt das für mich juli der hier
sozusagen zuständig ist sagt sie wollen
keine zahlen nennen sie wollen auch die
logistische route nicht nennen weil das
ist alles gefährlich aber ich frage
direkt nochmal nach so harmlos ist der
parlamentschef der will be no
der mine horizon hier in uk und
da sind wir
ganz oft gesprochen das kreditprogramm
ist also im sturm gewesen
so durcheinander
also wenn es keine anti flugverbots wenn
es keine flugverbotszone gibt dann
werden wir unser land anders verteidigen
dann werden wir auch so uns helfen
können aber ich wollte jetzt noch mal
nach ob es dringt sozusagen aus der
ukrainischen sichtbare benötigt wird
sowohl als to you need for germany so
lücken die fried russia ooo league in
streitberg schon mal der stürmer wie die
familie richtig
dass diese kalorien ihr hier finden
könnt
los ist wenn die was something
als er sagt wenn ihr schon nicht eine
flugverbotszone wollt wenn ich schon
nicht den himmel schließen können für
uns dann gibt uns mehr mit dem wir
sozusagen auf flugzeuge auf raketen
feuern können in dem fall spricht juli
vor allem von stinger raketen
raistinger is watching you need is
something strom ist ihm
das hilfsgesuch politische
gegenwart verlegt und nichts gewusst und
schon gar richtig wiedergeburt
helikopter 15 kilometer von hier
die russen haben mir gerade mit
helikoptern sagt der 50 kilometer von
hier weitere soldaten reinzubringen und
wenn es etwas gäbe mit dem sie sozusagen
auf diese helikopter feuern könnten dann
würde das der ukrainischen armee sehr
helfen letzte frage von uns hier paul
nachdem du uns ja wirklich einen sehr
exklusiven einblick gegeben hast du juli
wirkt wirklich sehr sehr cool muss man
sagen hat seinen humor auch offenbar
noch nicht verloren angesichts dieser
lage wenn er die waffen mit einem guten
alten volkswagen vergleicht sozusagen
ist er guten mutes dass die ukraine
diesen krieg gewinnen kann dass sie
aushalten kann zumindest dass kiew
verteidigt werden kann
die küste seiner lifestyle branche und
long term sheet juni die fans ukrainer
schotte
die russian
aber nicht über das lied und prestige
ist da geht die post am esstisch
abgeholt wurde
[Musik]
der erste ist schon sway telegate monate
hinter stoch passant war durch einen
magischen klang das ist
ja
ja schon wir
werden definitiv gewinnen da gibt es
keine chance so zusagen für eine
niederlage
sie sind bereit zu einem langen krieg
und sie werden diesen krieg gewinnen
sagt julie hier live in diesem moment
aus einem waffenlager mitten im hier
thomas unter anderem paul ganz
herzlichen dank für diese wirklich
außergewöhnlichen einblicke dort und wir
wissen jetzt auch wo die deutschen
waffen gelandet sind wie gesagt das war
die frage die friedrich mehr als heute
im bundestag an olaf scholz gestellt hat
und paul hat sie uns beantwortet danke
paul